le code général des collectivités
territoriales dispose que le maire
assure la tranquillité la salubrité et
la sécurité publique ça fait des années
qu'on demande plus de moyens pour nos
polices municipales et je me rappelle de
certains débats avec même des députés
Renaissance quand je leur disais au
moment de la réforme des retraite ou
est-ce qu'on peut pas en profiter aussi
pour aligner les policiers municipales
avec les policiers nationaux j'avais
droit à des réponses méprisantes ça fait
des années qu'on le demande mais en
dehors de cela donc déjà un donné au
maire le faire le rendre vraiment
j'allais dire magistrat premier
magistrat de la ville c'est une c'est un
titre en réalité vide et c'est aussi
là-dessus que nous devons réfléchir
après oui je suis pour plus de moyens
pour nos
[Musique]
poli tout de suite sur Public
Sénat
[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue nous sommes en
direct sur l'antainne de Public Sénat
programmation spécial toute la semaine
pour suivre cet événement qui se tient à
Porte de Versailles de Paris le 105e
congrès des maires de France avec de
très nombreux sujets d'inquiétude pour
les maires que ce soit la crise du
logement les violences et ainsi civilité
qui touche les élieux locaux la
complexité des normes également ils sont
plusieurs milliers réunis ici à la Porte
de Versailles une quinzaine de ministres
également qui vont venir participer au
débat avec un thème cette année choisi
par le Congrès et bien c'est les
communes attaquées et la République
menacée 4 mois après les émeutes qui ont
touché plusieurs centaines de villes en
France on va adresser ensemble les
enjeux de ce 105e congrès des maires de
France mais avant de vous présenter mes
invités sur ce plateau voyez le résumé
des enjeux avec Cécile
Siou juillet dernier la maison du maire
de l'ailer rose est attaquée une
agression devenue symbole et un
électrochoc les Mair en première ligne
face à la violence n'en peuvent plus sur
albol cette lassitude a été choisie
comme thème principal du Congrès des
mares sous le titre commune attaquée
République menacée le président de la MF
espère cette fois être entendu cette
violence sur les élus locaux que la MF
avait dénoncé en premier face à laquelle
nous avons fait un nombre certain nombre
de propositions qui sont toujours en
cours d'examen dans notre discussion et
qui n'aura de substance que si elle se
traduit en acte législatif réglementaire
exécutif l'autre inquiétude des maires
leur capacité d'action de plus en plus
limitée des édiles freinés par des
ressources financières faibles d'une
part mais aussi étouffé par le poids des
normes la loi climat et résilience pour
citer un exemple parmi d'autres euh du
22 août de mémoire 2021 à des
dispositions euh que l'on retrouve dans
les ZFE dans les DPE ou dans les anes la
malédiction des acronymes à trois
lettres enfin des sigles à trois lettres
en l'occurrence euh et bien qui entrave
l'action publique qui la rendent plus
lourde plus difficilez enfin dans les
través du salon les maires devraient
parler décentralisation
Emmanuel Macron a demandé à Eric vert
des pistes de réforme pour simplifier et
clarifier le millefeuil administratif
français il s'agira surtout de redorer
et valoriser le mandat de maire et
d'éviter l'hémorragie des démissions
jamais vu jusque- là selon l'Association
des maires de France voilà on va parler
des violences urbaines des relations
avec les concitoyens du poids des normes
voici quelques un des grands en je de ce
congrès des maires de France pour en
débattre je vous présente les invités
sur ce plateau Bernard Gor bonjour vous
êtes journaliste à La Croix on voit
votre titre qui consacre un dossier
spécial zone urbaine zone rurale où va
l'argent de l'État également avec nous
Françoise Gatel sénatrice centriste d
ven bonjour madame Gattel vous êtes
présidente au Sénat de la délégation aux
collectivités territoriales également
avec nous Frédéric le Turc bonjour vous
êtes maire centriste d'aras un des
vice-présidents de l'Association des
maires de Fr et enfin Aurélie gros est
avec nous bonjour vous êtes maire sans
étiquette du Coudret Monceau c'est en
Nesson un mot avec vous si vous le
voulez bien Aurélie gros quel est votre
état d'esprit on le sait le Congrès des
Maires c'est aussi l'occasion d'une
tribune pour les élus locaux pour vous
les maires pour et bien parler à
l'opinion publique en général parler
aussi à l'exécutif c'est quoi vous votre
état d'esprit alors mon état d'esprit
c'est que ce congrès des maires ce Salon
des Maires s'ouvre effectivement c'est
une tribune pour les maires ça ouvre
encore ce fameux sujet d'une nouvelle
étape de décentralisation dont on on
parle depuis 2018 une promesse
d'Emmanuel Macron notamment après les
gilets jaunes et je dirais que mon état
d'esprit c'est de dire que arrêtons
maintenant de parler arrêtons de
discutailler arrêtons d'attendre soyons
concrets lançons cette étape de
décentralisation réellement redonnons du
pouvoir au maire redonnons des finances
aux maires avec peut-être un impôt dédié
puisque ça crée des difficultés dans nos
communes et arrêtons avec ces acronymes
à trois lettres qui empêchent les petits
maires de travailler et pour relancer
cette vocation qui est celle d'un élu
local et donc aussi les communes qui
sont loin des grandes métropoles et
donnonsleur un peu plus de moyens
Frédéric Le turque on voit le le mot
d'ordre il est fort choisi pour le
congrès cette année commune attaqué
République monassée on entendait les
sujets de la la décentralisation il y
aura aussi forcément l'inquiétude face à
la montée des violences cette année oui
je pense que vous avez mis le doigt sur
une vraie problématique c'est que les
les maires sont très exposés posé ils
sont en première ligne comme on le dit
souvent de toute une série de de sujets
de problématiques que vivent les
Français au quotidien que ce soit dans
les communes rurales dans les dans les
villes moyennes dans les métropoles sur
Paris et c'est vrai que on a besoin en
fait d'avoir une un état considérant et
l'État considérant c'est un état
bienveillant un état qui fait confiance
finalement aux collectivités locales qui
fait confiance au maires parfois on
s'interroge et ce qu'on veut simplement
c'est comme l'a dit le président Lisnard
plus de démocratie et moins de
bureaucratie Françoise Gatel un état
confiant c'est ce qu'on réclame à
l'Association des maires de France dans
un contexte où le président de la
République annoncé qu'il ne viendrait
pas à cette année qu'est-ce que ça dit
ça du message que veut envoyer
l'exécutif ah je ne sais pas moi je suis
pas l'interprète du président de la
République faut lui demander moi ce qui
ce qui m'intéresse beaucoup dans ce
titre donné au salon des mères qui est
grave qui est en même temps très
solennel c'est un appel à nos
concitoyens en disant réveillez-vous
citoyens parce que demain s'il y a plus
de M parce que c'est trop compliqué
parce que les maires sont agressés parce
qu'ils n'arrivent plus à rendre possible
ce qui est souhaitable vous êtes en
danger la République est en danger c'est
aussi simple que ça et je le dis avec
gravité et et simplicité et que moi je
pense qui nous importe et je suis
d'accord avec ce que vient de dire
Madame le Maire bon le diagnostic on le
connaît on ce qu'il faut faire alors
maintenant c'est quand est-ce qu'on y va
comment on y va et je pense que la
mission que le Président de la
République a donné à Eric vert et tout
le travail que nous menons au Sénat
aujourd'hui on doit aller au bout voilà
il y a vraiment le feu au lac on y va
tranquillement mais vraiment je dis
aujourd'hui l'heure elle est grave il
faut sauver non pas le soldat Ryan mais
il faut sauver les m il faut sauver la
volonté de s'engager
parce que je pense que on a connu des
périodes très difficiles la société
éruptive et aujourd'hui l'affaire elle
est des plus sérieuses et des plus
graves Bernard Gor un mot sur cette
absence du chef de l'État le
gouvernement lui dit avoir une écoute
attentive et il dit même parler le même
langage la même gramire que les maèires
ce qui manque maintenant c'est peut-être
des actes des preuves d'amour c'est ça
oui c'est ça alors on peut dire que la
partie de cache-cache si l'on peut dire
depuis maintenant un quinquen et demi
continue parce qu'il avait dès le début
était un petit peu attaqué sur le fait
qu'il n'était pas élu local qui manquait
ce ce sens du du du contact avec le
terrain inversement il a réussi après
avec brio son tour de France des m après
la crise des gilets jaunes donc il y a
toujours eu avec Emmanuel Macron ce à la
fois cette proximité cet éloignement là
il remet à plus tard en confiant une
mission à à Monsieur vert une réflexion
de fond sur la
décentralisation ça cré un peu sans
doute d'Impa science d'attente encore
une fois mais il est vrai aussi qu'il y
a d'autres priorités internationales qui
expliquent sans doute cette année son
son absence à ce salon en tout cas le le
président République qui recevra un
millier de Maes ce sera mercredi soir à
l'Élysée je voudrais qu'on regarde
quelques chiffres sur le contexte dans
lequel s'ouvre ce congrès parce qu'il
est morose on parle de 450 maires qui
ont démissionné chaque année depuis 2020
c'est un chiffre record c'était 350 par
an sur la précédente mandature parmi les
raisons qui expliquent ce chiffre on a
vu dans l'étude du svipof qu'il y avait
la trop forte exigence des citoyens les
relations difficiles avec l'État la
montée des violences ou enfin la
conciliation entre vie professionnelle
et son mandat d'élu vous ressentez sur
le terrain qu' a il y a un changement
dans l'état d'esprit des maires certains
ont démissionné ils étaient plus
nombreux que précédemment bien sûr
puisque le le contexte actuel avec les
citoyens il y a il y a quand même un
fort non respect des institutions de la
police de la justice ça va même jusqu'au
pompiers des des des des personnels de
santé donc aujourd'hui on on sent qu'il
y a un ralebol des citoyens qui retombe
même si le maire reste l'élu en qui les
citoyens ont le plus confiance il est
apporter le BAFF comme le disait
Monsieur le Maire donc aujourd'hui je
peux comprendre qu'un élu local par le
manque de moyens aussi c'est un
investissement de tous les jours quand
vous voyez qu'il y a des petites
communes avec des maires très investis
qui aujourd'hui se retrouvent avec un
demi-secrétaire de mairie ben moi je
plaide pour quelque chose je plaide pour
qu'aujourd'hui ces territoires qui sont
relativement éloignés qui sont des
petites communes qui n'ont pas forcément
les moyens il y a unersement
proportionnel et qui est un nombre
d'administratifs qui soit dédiés à ces
communesl vous vous retrouvez avec des
très grandes communes qui ont PL tort de
cabinet d'administration de DGA mais les
c'est les mêmes réglementation pour les
petites communes et quand vous avez une
demi-secrétaire partagé avec la poste et
ben je peux comprendre que les maires
ils en aient un peu ras la casquette
surtout quand on voit la disparition
effectivement de la taxe d'habitation on
est tous très heureux qu' a plus de taxe
d'habitation on est tous citoyens mais
quelque part il y a un désengagement de
la part des citoyens quand ils regardent
leur mère et notamment quand leur mère
leur dit bah je ne peux pas faire tel
équipement parce qu'on est un peu dans
une société de consommation les gens
disent bah oui mais bon quand même vous
pouvez on leur répond bah on va
augmenter les impôts bah si vous êtes
locataire ça ne touche plus le citoyen
de la même manière donc moi je suis pour
la répartition mais à un moment il faut
trouver des des des idées concrètes et
réinvestir également c'est bien les élus
mais il faut ré invvestir le citoyen sur
qu'est-ce qu' un élu un élu c'est un
citoyen qui s'engage et un maire bah
quand vous êtes maire d'une ville vous
êtes aussi maire de famille mais d'une
famille très nombreuse Bernard Gor vous
avez réalisé un supplément de votre
journal qui est consacré à ces
disparités entre la France rurale et la
France urbaine vous avez donc comme ça
une cartographie aussi de cet écart
entre le citoyen et aussi la réalité
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez oui je rebondis sur ce que vous
disiez sur la complexité peut-être
aujourd'hui qui est un des éléments
parfois de découragement des élus locaux
tout est devenu très comple hein les
financements croisés quand il faut aller
chercher des dotations c'est à la fois
l'argent qui vient de l'Europe qui vient
de de l'État qui vient de la région et
tout ça complexifie parfois
déresponsabilise aussi les choses et
puis c'est aussi la complexité parce que
aujourd'hui il y a plus des fonds qui
sont automatiquement qui qui arrivent
automatiquement il faut aller les
chercher les montages sont compliqués et
on a parfois pas le le les aides les
l'ingénierie pour arriver à à aller
chercher cet argent ça c'est quelque
chose qui qui a remontait beaucoup dans
le dossier qui portait beaucoup sur
l'argent les moyens donnés par l'État
aux collectivités locales alors on le
disait le mot d'ordre de ce congrès
c'est commune attaqué République menacée
dans le contexte de ces émeutes qui sont
tenus dans 533 communes fin juin début
juillet un/ers de ces communes étaient
des communes politiques de la ville mais
donc 2 tiers ne l'étaient pas à propos
de cela écoutez le témoignage du maire
PCF de rive de Giet c'est une commune
plutôt rurale dans la BAN lieue de
Saint-Étienne dans le département de la
Loire elle a été touchée par ses émeutes
on va écouter son témoignage on y
revient juste après en plateau les
émetiers ontt forcé la la porte ont
cassé la porte pour rentrer et ont mis
le feu en mettant de l'essence dans les
containeur poubelles et ont mis le feu
ici donc ici tout tout a pris feu les
flammes sont montées le long des des
murs et puis ces fumées noires épaisses
se sont accumulé ici au 2è étage et la
chaleur a dégondé les portes ça polluit
l'ensemble de des locaux de l'hôtel de
ville ça fait fondre tout tout tout le
câblage électrique toute
l'informatique ça été un vrai désastre
et quand on est rentré là-dedans on a eu
le sentiment de d'être dans une scne de
film c'était incroyable paysage calciné
quoi voilà
ouais c'est ça a été des moments
difficiles à gérer pour pour les maire
il y en a eu pour 730 millions d'euros
de dégâts en 8 jours d'meutes ça a été
un choc dans vos communes
oui ça a été la laassidération dans dans
de nombreuses communes en France et pas
simplement je dirais celle que l'on
avait l'habitude de voir exposer donc ça
renvoie finalement à à une vraie
problématique comme vous le disiez euh
du sens et de la relation en fait du
citoyen avec son territoire de la
manière dont il a en fait conscience euh
notamment quand il est jeune euh de de
de la manière dont les conséquences de
ces actes-là ont des répercussions sur
les budgets des communes les budgets en
fait d'une manière générale de de l'État
quand on on expose un impôt en fait à
être réinvesti dans des biens qui
existaient déjà forcément c'est autant
de choses en fait que l'on a en capacité
de moins faire en tout état de cause
c'est inadmissible on l'a dit on l'a
défendu l'État en fait le gouvernement a
organisé une sorte de conseil national
pour travailler sur les violences
urbaines mais je pense que plus qu'un
conseil national il faut en fait fait
qu'on se repose la question peut-être de
l'éducation de la manière dont on on
place le rapport à la démocratie le
rapport à l'État dont on explique
finalement la manière dont ça fonctionne
en France et qu'on le fasse à l'école
plus on travaillera en direction des
enfants très tôt et mieux ce sera
Françoise Gattel ces éutes elles
participent forcément des d'esprit Moros
des MRES aujourd'hui à l'ouverture de ce
congrès comment voulez-vous avoir envie
de vous engager quand vous voyez toutes
les actions que vous avez AZ réalisé
misise à bas et qu'il va falloir
redépenser de l'argent comment vous-même
vous êtes interpellé violenté et votre
famille et moi je crois beaucoup à ce
que dit Monsieur le Maire c'est-à-dire
il y a un sursaut la justice doit
vraiment aussi faire son travail et on a
au Sénat voté une proposition de loi sur
une meilleure sécurité des élus un
partenariat renforcé entre le maire et
le monde de la justice et la clé elle
est dans l'éducation et l'éducation
c'est d'abord je crois la famille aussi
qui doit transmettre un certain nombre
de valeurs républicaine c'est-à-dire on
est à la fois un individu avec sa sphère
privée mais c'est comme dans une famille
vous êtes membres d'une famille vous
êtes membrre d'une société puis à
l'école on doit redécouvrir les choses
et moi je voudrais saluer toutes les
initiatives extraordinaires qui sont
prises par les maires les conseils
municipaux des jeunes et ils sont très
nombreux l'argent poche un certain
nombre d'actions qui sont faites et
aussi aujourd'hui les maires qui
organisent des temps de parentalité
c'est-à-dire on a aussi il faut
condamner personne on a des familles
pour qui la vie est compliquée et
difficile et c'est là où on voit que le
maire c'est un éternel réparateur
c'est-à-dire il vient compenser là où
les gens sont en difficulté mais il faut
qu'on ose aujourd'hui présenter une
image des élus qui soit vertueuse et
respectable et je pense qu'il faut qu'on
S mais ça n'est plus le cas aujourd'hui
de cet élu bachine on on va vous faire
réagir de côté du plateau mais on va
écouter Élisabeth born qui et bien a
pris la parole c'était après ses émeutes
elle a annoncé à la sonne le 26 octobre
dernier un fond pour la réparation on
l'écoute on continue en débattre en
plateau 60 % des bâtiments public
partiellement ou totalement détruit ont
d'ors et déjà été remis en état vous
pouvez compter sur la mobilisation des
services de l'État et nous veillons à
celle des assurances l'état l'état vous
accompagnera et je vous annonce qu'une
enveloppe de 100 millions d'euros pourra
être mobilisée pour vous aider à la
réparation et à la reconstruction en
complément de l'indemnisation des
assurances Aurélie gros une réaction la
réponse de l'exécutif elle était au
niveau alors j'y étis vous tbez bien à
la Sorbonne il y a eu pas mal d'annonces
euh moi je crains toujours les effets
d'annonce c'està dire qu'il y a plein
d'idées elles sont bonnes donner un peu
plus de pouvoir aux police municipal oui
qui pourront faire des actes po beauoup
plus les réparations mais tout ça c'est
de l'administratif pour les communes ça
se fait pas automatiquement quand on
veut rénover un bâtiment quand on veut
financer des caméras ils nous ont
annoncé qu'il y avait encore un fond
énorme pour financer notamment les les
caméras de vidéoprection c'est des
dossiers qui sont très complexes pour
notre administration donc quand on a une
toute petite administration bah elle a
pas pas forcément le temps de remplir
ces dossiers fait par des hauts
fonctionnaires situés à Paris dans les
ministères donc il faut se remett à
niveau de de de tout ça on peut pas
laisser les maires systématiquement on
leur dit on vous aide mais si on veut
vraiment aider il faut simplifier si on
veut vraiment recréer cette envie de
s'investir pour l'autre il faut les
aider dans la simplification notamment
administrative Bernard oui c'est cette
ce sujet là rejoint un peu le le le
dossier de fond qu'on a essayé de
traiter dans la croix lesbdo c'est
comment l'État soutient-il véritablement
ces territoire comment le mesurer
comment alors ce qui nous a frappé c'est
à quel point tout ça est extrêmement
opaque les chiffres sont terriblement
compliqué à essayer de de de faire
parler quand on se penche sur les
dotations quand on se pense sur le
fonctionnaires voilà alors on essaie de
mettre tout ça à plat mais c'est vrai
qu'il y a souvent beaucoup de
communication de la part du gouvernement
on pense à T ces plans annoncés sur les
petites villes de demain sur les ceci
cela et mais au fond quel est vraiment
l'effort de l'État pour les communes
rurales pour les quartiers urbains c'est
très compliqué d'y voir clair et on a
essayé un peu de de creuser tout ça
juste une réaction Françoise Gattel vous
le voyez forcément ce ce questionnement
sur tout toute cette architecture
impossible à à quantifier alors au Sénat
c'est c'est notre quotidien nous sommes
les élus des élus donc nous on est une
sorte de haut-parle l' et je pense qu'il
y a la fois un accompagnement de l'État
et sur ce qu'a dit la première ministre
au moment de l'accompagnement des
communes pour reconstruire vite et
réparer ça a été une très bonne réaction
et elle le fait je pense que elle est
convaincu on va le voir sur des annonces
autour des communes nouvelles après on a
une machine administrative qui est très
compliquée moi quand j'étais maire je me
souviens de réunion à la préfecture il y
avait 7p personnes à côté de moi et on
me disait madame vous avez une très
bonne idée mais ça va pas être possible
bah si il faut que ce soit possible
parce qu'il faut que le maire il puisse
agir un dernier mot sur les émeutes on
ira sur la simplification s'il vous
plaît sur les émeutes en fait simplement
je pense qu'il faut essayer de de faire
que dans les territoires la relation de
travail entre police justice
collectivité locale et partenair soit je
dirais forte et que cette relation de
confiance en fait permett de construire
du surmesure parce que ce qui est vrai
dans mon territoire n'est pas vrai à Mar
Marseille ou à Paris il faut en fait
qu'on donne de l'agilité aux politiques
publiqu et et la première ministre qui
parle d'une force d'action républicaine
qui va faire peut-être du cou humain
c'est une bonne annonce ça oui mais
encore faut-il en fait voir concrètement
comment comment les choses vont
s'organiser avec quels moyen si le cou
humain en fait repose uniquement sur les
moyens des collectivités locales ça ne
fonctionnera pas il faut qu'à un moment
donné les actes soi en rapport avec les
moyens et que l'agilité et la confiance
permettent de construire du cou humain
sur mesure mais avec des Mo et des
soutiens réels de l'État alors on le
disait c'est l'un des enjeux aussi de ce
congrès la simplification le problème
des normes aussi les questions autour de
la décentralisation c'est un des grands
enjeux aussi de ce congrès écoutez le
témoignage d'un maire croisé dans les
allées par les journalistes de Public
Sénat sur la difficulté notamment
d'appliquer le zan le zéro
artificialisation net des sols qui est
un objectif que vise le gouvernement
écouter la difficulté pour les élus
locaux c'est compliqué pour nos petites
communes parce que d'abord souvent on
est loin des pôles économiques on est
aussi loin des pôles qui se sont créés
en ce qui concerne tout ce qui est les
zones commerciales
et donc nous on nous a demandé au départ
de nous étaler et maintenant on nous
demande de nous regrouper ce qui n'est
pas évident évidemment et il faut
réussir en plus à construire en quelque
sorte à
étage et c'est pas une notion dans les
petites communes qui est norm mal on a
plutôt une maison son jardin et cetera
et là il va falloir réduire les espaces
réduire les maisons construire sur
plusieurs étages donc tout ça ça va
changer aussi les habitudes des gens
Frédéric le Turc c'est un casse-tête le
zan on vous en parle beaucoup c'est un
casse-tête et une absurdité parce que je
pense qu'on on veut faire
rentrer un aménagement du territoire et
une organisation des territoires en fait
sans réfléchir à la manière dont
l'habitant le citoyen veut évoluer et
vivre les merses sont exposés en fait à
des attentes diverse et multiple quand
une entreprise veut s'implanter elle
veut s'implanter là où elle le décide
quand un habitant en fait veut habiter
quelque part
veut concrétiser son projet de famille
je dirais que il va pas en fait se
référer aux zânes pour décider de
l'endroit où il va loger sa famille dans
un appartement ou dans une maison je
suis dans un un département qui est
touché par les inondations actuellement
et et forcément en fait ça réinterroge
l'ensemble des politiques publiques et
notamment les plans locaux d'urbanisme
et et l'ensemble en fait du travail qui
est fait par les collectivités locales
avec l'État mais si le zan s'impose
comment voulez-vous reloger les
personnes en fait qui ne pourront plus
éventuellement habiter dans les endroits
qui étaient urbanisés jusqu'à maintenant
comment voulez-vous repositionner les
entreprises qui ont besoin en fait
d'avoir une perspective Lausane en fait
c'est une une vraie mauvaise solution je
pense aux problématiques d'urbanisation
et on est tous d'accord pour faire des
économies de consomation foncière oui
sur sur l'étalement urbain il y aura des
efforts à faire par tous mais les les
objectif étaient irréalistes quand vous
les avez adopté quand vous les avez voté
au Parlement Françis je pense que ce
zéro artificialisation net c'est
l'exemple même de ce que l'on dit
l'enfer est pavé de bonnes intentions on
doit préserver des terres agricoles on
est tout à fait ok mais ensuite on doit
réindustrialiser ramener de l'emploi
avoir une indépendance industrielle et
chacun le sait que pour la même
population aujourd'hui vous devez
construire plus de logements parce qu' a
la décohabitation garde alterné et
cetera et que on a comme d'habitude
décidé qu'à Paris on savait tout et que
donc il fallait qu'en 2031 on est
consommé que la moitié de terre qu'on a
consommé avant en 2051 sauf que on na
pas du tout travaillé avec les élus
locaux et on s'est pas rendu compte que
ce qui se passe dans le Nord ou dans ma
Bretagne ça n'est pas la même chose que
dans la creux et on aurait dû et ça
c'est une leçon qu'il faut tirer parce
qu'on y arrivera pas sinon c'est comment
on dit à des élus locaux voilà quelle
proposition vous nous faites pour
diminuer votre consommation agricole et
dernier point c'est que zéro
artificialisation net c'est un vrai
danger avec un risque d'éteindre la
lumière dans les campagnes parce que si
vous ne pouvez consommer que la moitié
de ce que vous avez consommé vous avez
consommé zéro ça veut dire que
l'aménagement du territoire qui tient
tant à cœur à la première ministre euh
bah vraiment on a un problème ça veut
dire qu'à un moment on a cru qu'on
pouvait mener la France comme un
hororsbord alors que les questions
d'urbanisme c'est comme la conduite et
le pilotage d'un PACBO donc encore une
fois on s'est un peu trompé Aurélie gros
c'est symptomatique de ce qui se joue
avec dans la relation avec l'État c'est
des lois climat qui sont en fait des
actions de recentralisation de la
décision alors pour moi c'est des des
instructions contradictoires c'estàd
qu'aujourd'hui on a la loi des chiffres
voyez il faut zéro personnes dans les
rues il faut 25 % de logements sociaux
zéro artif officialisation des sols donc
on nous impose plein de réglementations
comme C là mais à côté de ça moi j'ai un
exemple concret quand l'État a un
terrain qui lui appartient est-ce que
vous pensez qu'il appelle le maire pour
savoir ce qu'ils veulent faire du
terrain comme on est en révision
générale du PLU par exemple dans ma
commune vous penser qu'il m'interroge
dans leur appel à projet pour savoir ce
qu'ils vont faire et ben non ils
décident de prendre 4 hectar 5 pour le
vendre à quelqu'un qui va faire de la
logistique en entrée de ville de ma
petite commune j'ai déjà 450 entreprises
4000 emplois sur ma commune 50 % de
terre agricole et l'État décide de
prendre un quartier complet pour faire
une usine est-ce que vous pensez qu'il
m'avertissent et ce qu' me demande si
j'ai besoin d'équipement public et ben
absolument pas et donc aujourd'hui une
commune comme la mienne est en procès
avec l'État parce que l'État ne veut pas
me vendre ou du moins veut bien me
vendre très cher comme une entreprise et
ben vous voyez on nous impose ça mais à
côté de ça l'état nous prend des amendes
sur avec la loiru puisque que nous
n'avons que 23 % de logements sociaux et
bien à un moment donné vous voyez ça
pour redonner de la confiance entre les
élus locaux et l'État comme le dit
Madame les décisions prises d'en haut
c'est assez compliqué après que les élus
s'engagent et confiance dans ce travail
partenarial donc oui ces loislà c'est
très bien je pense que quand on parle
développement durable quand on parle
réchauffement climatique tout le monde
doit être d'accord et ça part tout
d'abord avant des élus et des décideurs
et et de des des technocrates parisiens
ça part aussi des citoyens et je crois
qu'il faut plus se pencher sur ce que
veulent les citoyens dans leur communes
plutôt que de faire des lois générales
qui ne correspondent pas forcément à la
région parisienne comme le le le dou la
Creuse ou n'importe quel autre
département il faut aller au plus proche
du terrain et du territoire on voir vous
demandez de la confiance mais dans ce
contexte que que dire de la mission
fixée à vert par le chef de l'État qui
remet en question le millefeuille
territorial il serait trop compliqué
pour les français Emmanuel Macron qui
demande à de travailler à une
simplification des strates alors ça a
fait réagir jusqu'au président du Sénat
on va l'écouter c'était il y a 10 jours
au Congrès des départements de France
écoutez Gérard Larcher je ne crois pas
moi non plus un nouveau Big Bang
territorial je le redirai à Eric vert à
qui le président vient de confier une
mission relative à la
décentralisation la priorité n'est pas
la réduction du nombre de strates comme
je l'ai lu dans la lettre gardons-nous
des ponifs qui ont la vie dure et ne
revenons pas à quelques lub d'avant
l'été
2014 et cher François Sauvadet je
partage cette analyse qui est la
vôtre vous pouvez donc compter sur le
Sénat pour rester vigilant pour être au
côté des départements comme il le sera
au côté des communes au côté des régions
Frédéric leurc une réaction à ce qu'on
vient d'entendre bah moi je partage
complètement ce qui a été dit par le le
président Larcher je pense pas de Big B
territorial non pas de Big Bang
territoriale je pense pas de
simplification des strates je pense que
c'est pas le problème de la
simplification c'est l'état d'esprit la
manière en fait dont on exerce
finalement la relation de travail entre
l'État et les collectivité territoriale
entre les collectivités locales
territoriales et le citoyen c'est état
d'esprit qui compte ce qu'il faut
peut-être c'est remettre en question la
multitude d'agences qui sont venus en
fait s'imposer aux collectivités qui
sont venus en fait être en quelque sorte
des appels à projets successifs qui font
qu'on ne sait plus en fait pour un
certain nombre de communes vers qui se
diriger entre les agences et puis les
ministères et que tout ça devient très
complexe donnons un peu plus de
responsabilité au préfet permettons au
couplle préfet maire de travailler
intelligemment et et et finalement
cultivons et travaillons cet état
d'esprit qui doit nous permettre de de
d'avancer en fait simplement Françoise
Gatel le Parlement sera très vigilant le
Sénat la chambre des collectivité
territoriale qu'est-ce que vous
comprenez vous de la séquence qui
s'ouvre avec l'exécutif alors moi je
trouve que si le président de la
République décide de demander à Eric
vert qui a été maire de
réfléchir plus on est c'est plutôt pas
mal mais on a déjà des recettes puisque
alors je pense qu'il faut éviter le Big
Bang parce que à chaque fois qu'on en a
fait un on s'est planté enfin je
rappelle la loi n les régions donc si on
peut éviter de recommencer moi je pense
que les clés on les connaît on l'a dit à
Madame gourau quand on a travaillé sur
la fameuse loi déconcentration
décentralisation et cetera partons d'une
question simple c'est comment on rend le
service jusqu'au dernier kilomètre état
ou nous par un principe de subsidiarité
le mieux placé fait les choses et ceité
c'estd qu'il prend la place de l'autre
c'est ça voilà ce qui doit nous obcéder
c'est l'efficacité des choses donc
partons du service à rendre et après on
construit l'architecture une réaction
oui rapidement mais la loi 3DS c'était
sans doute que le début de quelque chose
et le choc de simplification est encore
certainement devant nous et attendu par
beaucoup d'élus locaux et c'est un des
sujets qu'on aborde dans notre dossier
sur d'où vient l'argent et où va
l'argent c'est vrai que certains
s'interrogent est-ce que c'est à
l'Europe de financer la la
réhabilitation de chemins ruraux est-ce
que c'est à l'état de financer le le les
tierslieux est-ce qu'il y a pas à
répartir un peu plus les l'échelle de
compétence en fonction de voilà de
l'Europe de l'état de des régions et des
départements
oligig alors moi je suis assez partagé
sur ce sujet-là parce que je pense que
effectivement les citoyens ont un petit
peu de mal à comprendre ce feuille
administrative on a eu la loi not la loi
maptam on a créé les agglomérations tout
çac a raison et je suis assez d'accord
avec Madame la sinatrice je dirais
partons du besoin des citoyens et des
territoires et remontons pour voir ce
que l'on peut simplifier par c'est assez
illisible bah on pense à la proposition
de Nicolas Sarkozy de fusionner les
départements et les régions avec des
conseillers territorials pour limiter le
nombre d'élus moi je suis à l'époque le
Sénat n'en voulait pas vous avez changé
d'avis au Sénat ça peut être une
solution finalement le conseiller
territorial fusionn conseiller général
et conseiller j'ai pas excusez-moi juste
pour compléter pour que vous puissiez
répondre dans l'ensemble notamment avec
avec les communautés d'agglomération qui
sont apparu qui sont qui ont été un peu
forcé hein surtout dans la région
parisienne qui ont été même très forcé
mais c'estàd qu'aujourd'hui vous avez
des communautés d'agglomération qui
pourraient prendre un certain nombre de
compétences directes en proximité du
terrain qui font d'ailleurs la taille de
département plutôt de de province donc
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il faut vraiment
arrêter de penser global il faut
vraiment partir des besoins donc c'est
pour ça que je parle du conseiller
territorial notamment dans les
métropoles madame Gatel cher Quentin
calm merci de poser les questions et de
faire les réponses mais la mienne n'est
pas celle-là c'est-à-dire non non mais
je je le dis très gentiment le
conseiller territorial a été une idée
vous l'avez rappelé de Nicolas Sarkozy
c'était avant la refondte des régions
exact et aujourd'hui quand vous avez des
grandes régions comme nouvel aququitaine
ou le Grand Est est-ce qu'on peut dire
que le conseiller territorial est aussi
pertinent moi je ne sais pas
c'est-à-dire aujourd'hui l'équation a
changé
tout cas ce qui me paraît important
c'est de dépenser mieux je vais vous
donner un exemple les nouvelles normes
qui ont été créées entre 2017 et 2022
vous savez combien ça coûte à nos
collectivités 2 milliards et demi
d'euros donc on n'est peut-être pas
obligé de faire ça ce serait déjà mieux
parce qu'en plus ça simplifierait la vie
moi je pense que ce qui est vrai on va
dire dans les haut de France ce qui est
vrai dans le Grand Est c'est pas
forcément ce qui est vrai dans ma région
de Bretagne on a quatre départements on
n pas bougé il y a une unité différente
mais peut-être peut-on proposer au
territoire de faire des proposition et
qu'on n'est pas obligé de porter tous le
même uniforme puisque c'est très à la
mode Frédéric leurque on arrive à la fin
de ce débat vous aussi vous prenez ce
cou humain peut-être dans la réforme
territoriale moi je suis plutôt
favorable en fait à un surmesure à un
coup humain qui tienne compte de la
manière dont les territoires en fait
sont il faut faire confiance surtout aux
citoyens je pense que contra à ce que
l'on peut penser les citoyens sont un
peu plus conscients de la manière dont
on est organisé en France par contre ils
veulent en fait qu'on soit efficace et
donc il faut qu'on améliore l'efficacité
de l'action publique faut qu'on puisse
s'engager peut-être dans de meilleures
évaluations de l'action publique je
pense que c'est surtout ça en fait qu'il
faut qu'on puisse réaliser tout
simplement je ne crois pas au choc new
big Bank comme le disait le président
d'archer je crois plutôt un travail de
fond qui va prendre du du temps il faut
éviter en fait d'imaginer que les choses
comme ça de manière très facile peuvent
se transformer du jour au lendemain et
le sujet des agence est un vrai sujet
parce que la multitude conduit à ce que
ça soit un peu complexe Bernard g le mot
de la fin juste peut-être pour nuancer
ça l'ennemi du cou humain c'est la
passion égalitaire française et ça ce
n'est pas que le problème de l'État
jacobin de la centralisation c'est aussi
en France une culture qu'on a de vouloir
l'égalité en se comparant les uns aux
autres qui ne facilite pas sans doute le
le coup humain avant d'accueillir
Stanislas Guerini le ministre de la
Fonction publique on va je voulais faire
réagir au thème de la première table
ronde qui se tient dans le Grand
Auditorium c'est réussir la transition
écologique dans le respect des libertés
locales on va on va l'écouter tout à
l'heure en longueur mais un mot sur et
bien l'intitulé même c'est bien que il y
a la volonté de faire la transition
écologique mais il y a des questions
aussi sur les compétences des maires on
est tous conscient qu'il faut
transformer nos territoires Esser de les
mettre jeais au niveau 2030 2050 et nos
citoyens sont très mobilisés sur ces
questionsl très sensibles je suis
persuadé que ça sera d'ailleurs l'un des
sujets majeurs des élections municipales
de
2026 mais on ne peut pas faire les
choses sans moyens et il faut qu'on
mette de l'ordre dans les priorités et
moi je reviens sur ce que je disais tout
à l'heure pour moi l'école c'est le
meilleur laboratoire qui peut permettre
aux citoyens de transformer en fait les
choses et finalement de s'engager dans
la société de ceain de de demain et je
voulais remercier le le président
Lisnard et puis André leniel d'avoir
finalement donné à ce congrès une
tonalité particulière en soulignant
l'engagement de Samuel paatti et
Dominique Bernard qui a été assassiné
comme vous saage je effectivement de
toute la MF effectivement on suivra ça
en plus en direct sur l'antenne de
public s un mot une réaction sur ce
thème réussir la transition écologique
dans le respect des des libertés locales
on voit c'est un peu la clé de voûe
aussi pour l'action des démer n'est-ce
pas c'est c'est un c'est un joli titre
j'espère que ça se passera comme ça
effectivement c'est pas en imposant des
normes des dates des obligations il faut
le coconstruire ensemble il faut le
coconstruire avec les citoyens cette
transition énergétique ne se fera pas
toute seule avec des décisions prises
d'en haut et je je pense que les élus
locaux et les maires notamment s'ils ont
les moyens auront l'occasion de pouvoir
engager selon les préoccupations de leur
territoire à leur mesure cette
transition écologique qui est nécessaire
et sur laquelle on est tous d'accord
Françoise Gatel tous dans détail on l'a
compris hein je je pense et je suis
persuadée que les maires sont des grands
faiseurs c'estd c'est eux qui font et
alors je vous invite tous alors c'est
pas une publicité mais c'est une
recommandation un bon conseil à lire le
rapport que la délégation collectivité
vient de sortir sur l'engagement des
collectivités sur la transition
écologique on a visité rencontré une une
trentaine de territoires des communes et
des territoires très diverses et de
toute taille et les actions qui sont
engagées par ces communes sont
absolument remarquables ça montre que
c'est possible et là encore l'État doit
accompagner parce que les choses ne se
feront pas à partir d'une injonction
nationale il faut emmener tous les
maires et il faut emmener chacun la dit
nos habitants parce que c'est avec cette
adhésion et cette promesse d'un avenir
positif on peut faire la transition
écologique sans avoir l'air de punir les
gens et moi je pense qu'on va y arriver
grâce aux élus Bernard GS oui pour
revenir à notre dossier de la Croix on a
quelques témoignages d'élus et notamment
je pense à celui-ci celui d'André Ferré
qui est MRE d'un petit village de
Saint-Julien dans la Loire et qui dit à
quel point son village aujourd'hui
regarde l'avenir avec avec enthousiasme
et en y croyant parce qu'il y a quand
même des des moyens il y a quand même
des dotations on a la possibilité de
créer il soulligne simplement un ou deux
points aveugles et notamment la question
de mobilité qui est pour eux le le gros
sujet des années à venir c'est la
question de de la mobilité oui une
réaction allez-y au réliieux à
totalement d'accord le sujet de la
mobilité et je pense qu'on peut aussi
emmener notre jeunesse parce qu'on
parlait tout à l'heure de la jeunesse on
parlait des violences urbaines et c'est
un sujet qui parle beaucoup à notre
jeunesse la transition écologique et
avec les écoles avec tous ces jeunes
c'est l'avenir pour demain donc
n'imposons pas ne faisons pas de
l'écologie punitive et laissons faire
aussi la la coconstru et la bonne
intelligence et bien merci merci à tous
les quatre je je vais vous libérer
Frédéric le Turc puisque vous devez
aller animer une table ronde si j'ai
bien compris dans le le Grand Auditorium
mais on va continuer ce débat avec tous
les trois je voudis qu'on écoute David
lissnard il était sur notre antenne il
réclame davantage de marge de manœuvre
face à l'inflation législative et parce
que c'est tout le lien avec le quotidien
des Français qui se joue écoutez le
président de l'association des MRES de
France ça fait quand même combien de
fois qu'on entend des annonces d'actes
de décentralisation puis qu'en réalité
on recentralise nos finances on est
soumis à des procédures croissantes
enfin et tous les maires vous le diront
donc ça j'ai dit qu'il fallait vraiment
maintenant passer à autre chose et y
compris au-delà de la décentralisation
sur la déconcentration des services de
l'État on est convenu d'ailleurs de de
position assez proche là-dessus mais il
faut que passer aux actes qu'on voulait
des actes voilà voilà c'est c'est
l'enjeu de ce congrès de passer aux
actes c'est ce que vous attendez de la
quinzaine de ministres qui vont être
présents pendant ces 3 jours
j'attends qu'ils soit à l'écoute des
maires qu'ils aillent vers et non pas
que ce soit les maires qui aillent vers
eux et qu'ils écoutent les réalités de
terrain qui sont jamais évidentes voilà
le quotidien est difficile donc
j'attends vraiment qu'il y ait une
réconciliation il y a des des ministres
très engagés on a des élus très engagés
et maintenant il faut montrer une image
un peu plus positive aussi à nos
concitoyens Françoise Gatel on saura que
c'est un congrès réussi pour les maires
comment ben écoutez je je sais pas moi
je pense que là il faut qu'on avance
parce que il y a une sorte de diagnostic
partagé et David lissnard le président
de l'association des MRES il mène des
combats essentiels c'est-à-dire que il
faut qu'on lâche les baskets aux élus
enfin moi je le dis simplement il faut
que l'État se détende il faut que
l'administration se détende aussi et on
a vu pendant la crise sanitaire où à un
moment il y avait à la fois des
protocoles très difficiles mais qu'il
fallait inventé des choses combien les
préfets l'administration et les élus ils
ont été géniaux ils ont inventé des
choses remarquables et on voit que quand
on s'affranchit de règles euh qui sont
trop lourdes les choses avant et en même
temps je voudrais dire que si les choses
sont compliquées ça n'est pas que la
faute du législateur ou la faute de
l'État mais c'est parce que nos
concitoyens sont compliqués exigeants
c'està-dire aujourd'hui on n'aime pas
leur risque et on doit les protéger de
tout de risque sanitaire de risque
écologique bientôt de la pluie voilà on
a un vrai sujet mais il faut qu'on
libère l'initiative et que ça a été dit
par Frédéric leur je pense qu'il faut
que les préfets et plus de pouvoir pour
apprécier les choses et considérer que
la norme qu'on impose à une petite
commune ça ne peut pas être la même que
celle d'une grande commune donc on a des
réponses on a les moyens c'est un état
d'esprit faut se détendre oui on vous
écoute c'est pendant que vous vous
expliquez pendant que vous vous exprimez
on va accueillir ici en plateau le
ministre Stanislas Guerini qui va
pouvoir s'installer allez-y Bernard oui
c'est plus plus de pouvoir peut-être au
préfet et plus de moyens aux préfectures
c'est quelque chose qui est remonté
aussi ça dans notre enquête c'est que
les préfectures ont perdu
en en nombre de fonctionnaires moins 10
% sur les sur quelques plusieurs années
alors l'arrivée de Monsieur Guerini
tombe bien parce qu'il y a eu toutes les
ouvertures des des maisons France
service on parlera peut-être qui a un
vrai succès mais c'est peut-être loin
encore de compenser les pertes qu'il y a
eu en effectif de personnel dans les
préfectures bonjour stanislasgerini
Merci de rejoindre sur le micro de au
micro de public sa en direct ici sur
notre antenne vous êtes ministre de la
Fonction publique on entend ce message
demandé par les maires davantage de
confiance c'est ce que vous êtes venu
dire au Mair c'est quoi votre message
vousortez dans les allées pendant 3
jours bah d'abord je voudrais dire que
je suis d'accord avec tout ce que vient
de dire la présidente Gatel mais je je
dis ça sans me forcer elle disait faut
se détendre faut lâcher la grappe
parfois de nos élus et je crois que
c'est très vrai en réalité vous utilisez
un mot qui est très important pour moi
qui est celui de confiance et dans tous
les débats qu'on peut avoir à chaque
fois revient cette idée qu'on peut tout
à fait respecter ce qui est le statut de
la fonction publique et se faire
confiance donner des marges de manœuvre
retrouver une liberté d'action et c'est
très vrai dans la dimension dont j'ai la
charge c'est-à-dire sur l'administration
quotidienne sur la gestion des
fonctionnaires moi je suis frappé de
voir à quel point parfois il y a des
choses qu'on ne sait plus expliquer moi
je je l'ai dit dans le cadre du débat
sur les secrétaires de mairie par
exemple je ne sais plus expliquer
pourquoi un maire ne peut pas promouvoir
des agents méritants si il en recrute
pas à l'extérieur alors que on a des
difficultés justement de recrutement
aujourd'hui je sais plus expliquer
pourquoi parfois on met tant de
barrières à l'entrée pour pouvoir euh
recruter dans la fonction publique
promouvoir bouger plus facilement et
donc le message que je suis venu porter
c'est exact celui-là on le fait au
quotidien on le fait en revalorisant un
certain nombre de métiers je suis venu
sur les adsem sur les secrétaires de
mairie mais il faut le faire plus
largement pour la fonction publique et
c'est je crois l'agenda qui nous attend
dans les prochains mois je voudrais vous
faire dialoguer avec une maire qui est
ici en plateau avec nous gr et MRE du
coura Monceau c'est en on et elle nous
réclame depuis le début de cette
émission un choc de simplification
allez-y je vous en prie vous pouvez
directement vous adressz à un memb de
l'écuistre merci en tout cas d'échanger
avec avec moi sur ce sujet c'est vrai
que la problématique moi qui me frae le
plus c'est sur les toutes petites
communes qui sont en manque cruel de
personnel puisqu'on se retrouve avec des
communes qu'on un demiagent par exemple
partager avec la poste et moi j'avais
une proposition qui est portée notamment
par un grand nombre de citoyens qui
vient qui viennent bénévolement aider
leurs élus parce que ça existe ça aussi
c'est qu'il ait une une part de
fonctionnaires qui soit affecté dans ces
petites commune c'est-à-dire qu'en gros
ce soit inversement proportionnel
c'estàdire que cette petite part puisse
être don à ces communes qui n'ont pas
d'employés et pourtant les mêmes normes
à respecter on a des très très grosses
communes qui sont remplies de DGA de DG
de de cabinets et vous avez des très
petites communes qui n'ont personne avec
les mêmes règlementation donc ça paraît
assez difficile pour ces Maes là en tout
cas de se réengager derrière voilà un
dialogue avec bien sûr d'abord je veux
dire que je partage évidemment ce que
vous êtes en train de dire on voit bien
que bien souvent il y a un besoin
d'accompagnement en matière d'ingénierie
il y a une complexité et Françoise Gatel
le disait à l'instant c'est normal que
l'administration d'une certaine façon
puisse emporter une part de complexité
parce que la vie des gens est complexe
parce qu'il faut apporter des réponses
mais il faut accompagner nos communes je
pense qu'il y a deux niveaux de réponse
il y a d'abord l'accompagnement en
matière d'ingénierie c'est l'état
déconcentré que vous mentionnez à
l'instant on se bat pour essayer de
redonner des moyens à notre état
déconcentré pour retrouver une qualité
de relation entre nos préfets et les
communes je pense que ça ça doit être
d'abord la prère part de mutualisation
le deuxème sujet c'est comment on peut
mieux mutualiser des compétences à
l'échelle par exemple des bassins de vie
à l'échelle des intercommunaités ou à
travers nos centres de gestion c'était
le cas vous mentionnez parfois des
emplois qui sont partagés on parlait à
l'instant des secrétaires de mairie on
voit bien que les secrétaires de mairie
parfois elles sont sur trois quatre
communes différentes et c'est un sujet
qui était cher en l'occurrence mais de
pouvoir porter dans les centres de
gestion c'est une compétence obligatoire
qu'on a inscrite dans la loi récemment
le fait fait de donner un rôle
d'animation ou de mutualisation à ces
centres de gestion parfois à des
intercommunalités pour pouvoir vous
mettre à disposition des agents bien
formés qui peuvent faire des
remplacements ou qui peuvent aussi
accompagner des jeunes qui rejoindrait
la fonction publique et qui ont besoin
de tutorat dans le début de leur
carrière donc je pense que c'est
exactement quelque chose surqu on une
réaction de Françoise Gatel ensuite je
vrais faire dialoguer aussi Bernard GS
avec vous monsieur le ministre mais
allez-y madame Gatel merci merci
beaucoup nous nous avons avec le
ministre Stanislas Guerini beaucoup
travaillé notamment sur les emplois de
secrétaire de mairie parce que quand on
parle de
donn n'est pas qu'une question d'argent
il nous manque aujourd'hui 1600
secrétaires de mairie et quand on sait
que dans les petites communes une
secrétaire de mairie fait un travail
vraiment impressionnant que le maire
peut rien faire sans les secrétaires de
mairie mais que parfois elles sont
employées 3 jours par semaine à 35 km de
le leur domicile et je vrais faire une
comparaison avec les déserts médicaux et
l'accès aux soins aujourd'hui on a du
mal à avoir des jeunes qui sont
secrétaire de mairie qui adorent ce
métier qui vont accepter de faire tous
les jours 30 km pour être 2 jours et
demi dans une commune 2 jours et demi
dans une autre sans aide et donc ce que
le ministre a proposé et ce que nous
avons soutenu et déjà fait au Sénat pour
les gardes champett c'est que si les
communes le souhaitent et si l'interco
le souhaite et le centre de gestion
devra le faire s'il y a pas d'initiative
intercommunale c'est que
l'intercommunalité porte des contrats de
travail pour des secrétaire de mairie
qui seront tempant partager l'avantage
ça veut dire que le maire le jour sa
secrétaire de mairie est malade où est
en vacances il aura une ressource et il
y aura des savoir-faes complémentaires
donc je pense qu'il faut aussi qu'on
invente des réponses un peu nouvelles
parce que les gens veulent travailler
autrement mais le ministre l'a dit il
faut qu'on permette à des maires qui
sont des des employeurs ils ont une
responsabilité de pouvoir gérer et
promouvoir le leur personnel comme il
l'entend Bernard Gorse jeist à la croix
je rappelle votre dossier spécial zone
urbaine zone rurale où va l'argent de
l'État vous nous avez parlé au début de
l'émission de la difficulté même à
quantifier à chiffrer tout ce qui est
fait dans les communes rurales dans les
départements ruraux vous avez le
ministre en face de vous vous pouvez lui
adresser un message poser des questions
oui alors sur cette difficulté l'opacité
finalement des chiffres pour comprendre
effectivement qui verse quoi et qui
reçoit quoi et ce qu'il y a euh il y a
une opacité sur les chiffres mais aussi
une complexité des dispositifs et ce qui
est revenu souvent dans notre enquête
c'est une remise en cause de de ces
financements croisés il y a de l'argent
qui arrive de l'Europe de l'état des
régions des agences nationales comme euh
pourôle emploi ou je bon et et plus
personne s'y retrouve et il y a une
certaine déresponsabilisation parce que
quand un un chantier capote et ben tout
le monde se renvoie la balle en disant
bah c'est la faute d'un tel ou un tel
une dernière réponse et après on ira
écouter les débats qui je je r très
simplement et très directement le bon
modèle c'est celui d'action cœur de
ville c'est celui des petites villes de
de main c'est celui des villages
d'avenir c'est-à-dire des modèles qui
sont assez souples sur les modalités où
on peut financer assez largement des
projets et qui ne constituent pas des
appels à projet où on gère 3000 € depuis
un territoire jusqu'au cabinet d'un
ministre voilà ça c'est l'antiodè il
faut arrêter avec ces appels à projets
et ce cloisonnement des politiques
publiques et il faut avoir des projets
qui partent du terrain d'où la mention
sur euh les bons exemples que constiue
par exemple action cord-deville sur
lequel on est de les souplesse de
financement et surtout de l'ingénierie
et de l'accompagnement des acteurs pour
faire le lien entre les deux parties de
notre discussion et bien merci merci
d'être venu sur ce plateau monsieur
Guerini merci à à tous les trois de
m'avoir accompagné depuis 11h on le voit
ce coup humain c'est l'un des enjeux clé
de ce congrès des maires de France
d'ailleurs on va aller écouter dans le
Grand Auditorium le tout premier débat
de ce ce congrès il est consacré au fait
de réussir la transition écologique dans
le respect des libertés locales bonjour
à toutes et à tous oui réussir la
transition écologique c'est fondamental
et nous tous élus on est tous motivés on
est dans les starting block même pluson
a même déjà démarré sur ce plan-l mais
comme c'est bien dit en respectant les
libertés locales et c'est ce à quoi nous
tenons particulièrement ça doit venir du
terrain de la commune et c'est nous sur
le terrain qui connaissons le mieux les
les problématiques c'est pas forcément
la même solution à un endroit ou un
autre là c'est l'école qu'il faut
restaurer là c'est au contraire la
biodiversité qu'il faut défendre enfin
partout mais les priorités l'ORD dans
lequel on fait est différent les les
chantiers sont sont énormes évidemment
la réservation énergétique on le on le
sait tous il y a ça l'éclairage public
on peut en parler euh la biodiversité il
faut il ne faut pas l'oublier parce que
je crois que c'est ce qui va nous
arriver dans la figure un peu plus tard
puisque c'est moins visible c'est moins
attendu mais c'est fondamental pour
l'avenir on doit être à la fois sur le
terrain pour être des citoyens du monde
si j'ose dire c'est des citoyens du
monde qui luttons contre le
réchauffement climatique mais on doit
aussi être là pour les finances de nos
communes les finances qui sont assez
limitées et sur lesquels il faudrait
avoir plus de visibilité il faudrait que
vraiment l'état fasse confiance au
terrain le plus possible alors je vais
pas être plus long parce que nous sommes
là pour faire des témoignages et puis
après voir des solutions et donc je ne
suis pas plus long et je vais on va
laisser la parole à tous ces en donnant
d'abord la parole à constence de Pichi
votre collègue parce que les politiques
d'aménagement sont bien sûr au centre de
ces problématiqu de transition
écologique et je rappelle que vous êtes
la la présidente de la commission
aménagement urbanisme habitat de la MF
merci B il devient difficile de penser
politique d'aménagement et transition
écologique sans avoir le spectre duusan
zéro artificialisation net l'acronyme
qui fait tant parler de lui et qui fait
si peur aux élus
aujourd'hui la question question qu'on
va se poser ensemble c'est comment
peut-on réussir le zanne sans avoir le
sentiment que nos politiques
d'aménagement sont désormais imposé
directement par les services de l'État
et et en particulier par nos préfectures
au contraire comment peut-on faire pour
réussir cette trajectoire de limitation
de l'artificialisation des sols tout en
respectant la promesse démocratique sur
laquelle nous avons été élus on n pas
encore la solution mais la réflexion
commune nous permet peut-être de dégager
des pistes on va dégager des
propositions et peut-être aussi voir
comment vos collègues dans leur
territoire portent des des des solutions
locales et arrive à trouver des
convergences entre ces politiques et
tous ces impératifs on commence avec
vous Jean-François Vigier je vous
présenta tout à l'heure maire de de Bur
survette et quand on évoque les
difficultés que vous rencontrez dans la
mise en œuvre des des des politiques
vous me disiez que il y a aussi parfois
des contradictions dans l'administration
de l'État et vous aviez un exemple bien
concret quand il s'agit de de faire et
bien de la rénovation énergétique des
bâtiments
oui bonjour à tous bonjour monsieur le
ministre bonjour mes chers collègues
effectivement cette table ronde c'est le
signe de la liberté d'agir et aussi de
la la capacité de financer et sur la
liberté d'agir et sur la
nécessité pour l'état de parler d'une
seule voix et notamment l'état des
entrer dans nos territoires j'ai même
deux exemples le premier exemple c'est
celui de la rénovation énergétique des
bâtiments et des habitation puisque
l'État a donné une impulsion il faut que
nous réussissions la transition
énergétique et il faut que tout le monde
élu citoyens rénovent leurs habitations
il se trouve que depuis un an dans ma
commune mais je pense que je ne suis pas
le seul je reçois les premières demandes
d'isolation par l'extérieur et de PO de
panneaux photovoltaïqu on va de l'avant
sauf que l'ABF dit
non en
gros un état qui avance vers la
transition écologique et il y a un
service de l'État je dirais un peu plus
artiste qui estime que l'isolation par
l'extérieur se marie mal avec
l'environnement et donne un avis
défavorable la deuxième exemple que je
voudrais donner c'est sur la loi AP la
production d'énergie renouvelable où
nous avons la loi prévoit qu'au 31
décembre les ma doivent faire des
propositions définir des des endroits
pour installer de l'énergie
renouvelable la ministre madame
panierunach a annoncé que la loi le 31
décembre n'était pas une date butoire et
c'est très important or il y a des
préfets qui disons-le font du Zè dans
certains départements et poussent à ce
que le 31 décembre soit respecté je dis
que il faut impérativement laisser la
liberté au maire quand il s'agit
d'installer des éoliennes dans une
commune sur un terr teroire le temps de
la discussion avec les citoyens est
indispensable au risque d'amener à
l'immobilisme donc il faut donner de la
souplesse tout ne doit pas descendre de
façon autoritaire et puis la souplesse
mais aussi des directives qui qui soient
clair cohérente avec les politiques
mises en œuvre et vous avez été assez
actif sur un dossier qui était celui des
des fausses consignes de bouteilleill
plastique c'est un sujet qui touche à la
liberté d'agir et au financement et je
veux d'abord dans un premier temps
remercier c'est christiophe Béchu notre
ministre qui a eu un un discours sans
ambigué sur cette question de fausse
consignes et qui nous a soutenu dans ce
combat que nous avons mené avec les
collectivités locales avec tous les
organismes contre cette aberration
environnementale que serait la fausse
consigne sur les bouteilles plastiques
vous êtes battu à nos côtés et grâce à
vous elle n'a pas été mise en œuvre au
1er janvier 2024 il faut maintenant
monsieur le ministre que le plan de
recyclage élaboré par les collectivités
qui vous le savez est très ambitieux
soit mise en œuvre sans tarder de façon
à ce que nous atteignonss ensemble les
objectifs fixés par la loi AGEC là on
est bien justement sur des cohérences
entre les politiques qui sont menées
depuis de longues années sur la la
valorisation des des déchets et puis
aussi sur des questions de financement
parce que au final quand on on atterrit
sur toutes ces ces politiques
environnementales et bien il y a il y a
ce ce ce mur financier qui est devant
nous alors oui c'est un mur financier
parce qu'on en voit pas le haut euh et
en tant que maire moi je je m'interroge
sincèrement comment on va arriver à tout
faire dans les délais qui nous sont
donnés l'Institut de l'économie pour le
climat
a chiffré à 12 milliards d'euros chaque
année entre 2020 et 2030 les
investissements à réaliser par les
collectivités locales sur la transition
pas les autres investissements des
communes uniquement ce axés sur la
transition on sait aujourd'hui que
chaque année les collectivités
locales dépensent 5 milliards et demi
sur la transition vous voyez le gap donc
forcément on peut avoir le fond vert
pérénisé c'est très important les
contrats régionaux les contrats
départementaux comment arriver en haut
de ce mur du financement parce que il y
a quand même une notion à laquelle on
était pas forcément habitué aussi
massivement c'est celle de l'urgence on
a eu des routes qui s'effondre on a eu
des faux plafonds qui tombent dans des
écoles ou dans des centres culturels à
réparer en urgence mais
refaire énergétiquement les écoles les
gymnases les mairies annexes les centres
culturels les centres techniques on n
jamais eu ça en quelques
années sauf que nous les maires nous
votons des budgets en équilibre et notre
capacité d'endettement elle est limitée
et on sait tous ici que si on dépasse 10
11 12 13 ans de capacité de
désendettement tout de suite on est
placé en cellule d'alerte préfecture la
DG FIB débarque en mairie et nous vous
explique comment dépenser donc ça veut
dire comment fait-on pour dépenser
autant investir autant pour répondre à
cette stratégie nationale et que nous
partageons tous soit on décorrèle les
investissement dédié à la transition et
on nous autorise à nous endetter pour
des durées très longues une sorte de
dette verte ou alors
disons-le aujourd'hui nous n'avons plus
de fiscalité de résidence depuis la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation il y
a une profonde inégalité parce que nos
politiques publiques ne sont financées
que par les propriétair alors on viendra
à d'autres moments du conès il faut donc
il faut donc sûrement une véritable
fiscalité de résidence qui nous permette
de faire face aux enjeux qui sont devant
nous en terme de transition écologique
pouvoir financer avoir les moyens de
porter des des des projets Vanessa
Miranville vous êtes maire de de la
possession à l'île de la Réunion
33500 habitants de de l'océan Indien
jusqu'au haut de de de avec un
territoire très très divers et puis euh
un un un vrai partiprix de politique
environnementale que vous portez et un
dialogue parfois difficile avec les les
services déconcentrés de l'État quand il
s'agit de de mettre en œuvre et d'avoir
les les moyens de mettre en œuvre le
premier exemple que vous me donniez
quand on préparait ce ce débat c'était
celui de la
revégétalisation racontez-nous ça alors
bonjour bonjour monsieur le ministre
bonjour chers collègues alors juste pour
resituer parce que je viens de loin et
parfois on connaît peut-être mal les
outr-merses donc la Réunion c'est un
territoire qui avec les autres outr-mèes
regroupe 80 % de la biodiversité
française donc c'est dire même si nous
sommes petits géographiquement mais nous
sommes importants en terme de
biodiversité effectivement nos communes
et la mienne en particulier va vont de
du Battan des lames au sommet des
montagnes euh donc nous avons des
programmes de revégétalisation important
euh mais qui ont la la difficulté de
n'être financé que sur une durée de 3
ans or quand on fait ces programmes on
va planter sur une deux et jusqu'à la 3è
année et il faut ensuite de l'entretien
sur encore 3 ans supplémentaires pour
être sûr que les espèces endémiques et
et indigènes qu'on a planté puissent
prendre le pas sur les espèces
envahissante exotique et malheureusement
là les financements s'arrêtent au bout
de cette 3e année ça nous oblige donc à
financer des postes notamment à travers
des employd les les pecs don dont nous
avons aussi énormément besoin
notamment dans dans dans nos territoires
pour insérer professionnellement et
socialement des des personnes en
difficulté sauf que le nombre de PEC va
aussi diminuer donc on se retrouve
coincé aussi de de ce côté-là et bah on
a des espèces en envissantre qui
reprennent le pas sur des espaces qui
ont été revégétalisés ou parce qu'on
connait tous maintenant en métropole le
moustique tigre mais vous avez
malheureusement le le privilège d'avoir
des espaces des espèces exotiques
envahissantes et là aussi c'est une
politique non seulement environnementale
mais aussi de santé publique à mener
exactement un exemple très concret le
poil à gratter c'est une espèce
envahissante et qui malheureusement fait
des gousses à proximité même des
habitations il suffit qu'une gousse
s'ouvre qu'elle qu'elle se propage et on
peut être sur sur sa véranda bon nous on
a le le privilège de pouvoir être assez
souvent sous la véranda et là c'est des
démangeaisons pendant des jours et des
jours nos agents environnement sont
obligé pour aller recueillir ses gousses
de mettre des combinaisons intégrales à
35°gr à l'extérieur sous combinaison
vous imaginez la la pénibilité que c'est
et en fait on on perd le combat parce
que les gousses se propagent et et vont
recréer de de nouvelles plantation enfin
plant et voilà c'est c'est un combat
vraiment de longue haline et un combat
qui nécessite me disiez-vous de
péréniser des des moyen parce que sinon
bah si on fait les choses à moitié on
les fait pas du tout quoi ça marche pas
exactement alors on a des plans de lutte
antictorielles contre le moustique mais
il faudrait là je pense un plan de lutte
contre les espèces envahissantes
exotiques qui vraiment un peu à l'instar
de ce que les États-Unis ont fait quand
ils ont créé les parcs nationaux he
Yosémite a été créé comme ça on a eu la
crise de 1929 la crise c'est aussi
peut-être l'opportunité de faire des
choses là on vit une crise B c'est
peut-être l'opportunité de de d'insérer
socialement des personnes qui vont aider
notre environnement à pouvoir se
préserver pour nous et pour les les
générations à venir et puis des
politique d'aménagement et là vous avez
en particulier un projet d'écoquartier
et bah ça coince encore oui alors notre
écoquartier donc c'est il est en phase 2
de de la bisation donc on est sur une
surface de 30 hactares pour 1800
logement et dont 900 sont déjà livrés
donc c'est c'est quand même un projet
conséquent et et qui a vraiment vocation
à faire de l'aménagement durable et je
pense que ça peut même être un un projet
un peu pilote parce que finalement les
problématiques de lutte contre les îlos
de chaleur urbains que la métropole
commence à connaître nous la chaleur on
connaît ça depuis un petit moment et
donc les le l'utilisation de la
ventilation naturelle de des brises
soleil de la végétalisation de tous ces
systèmes qui permettent de de ne pas
avoir à à recourir à la clime voilà on
les maîtrise et on les a déjà
expérimentés dans cet écoquartier alors
tout le monde devrait être content et
les services de l'État aussi vous
trouvez exemplaire oui sauf que une fois
qu'on a bah la rtaad ou la RTA pour pour
le la métropole les réglementations
thermiques elle s'arrêteent à au moment
de de la conception du bâtiment sauf que
derrière il y a l'usage et quand
quelqu'un finalement décide de mettre
une clime malgré tout alors qu'on est
dans un écoquartier ou décide de couper
des traits qu'on met sur les bâtiments
pour rafraîchir on n'a pas les moyens
réglementaires de contrôle de
sensibilisation aussi parce que bah à
nouveau pour sensibiliser à l'écologie
au fait de vivre dans un écoquartier bah
il faut des personnes qui aillent
rencontrer les habitants au quotidien
pour leur expliquer pourquoi c'est
important de préserver son environnement
de ne pas arracher la plante qui a été
plantée parce qu'on la trouve jolie pour
aller la mettre sur son balcon ça arrive
aussi voilà et donc ça arrive partout et
oui donc il faut à la fois des bah des
financements pour pour des personnes qui
vont avoir ce ce rôle là on a mis par
exemple des des compteurs énergétiques
il faut du coaching avoir le compteur
c'est bien mais avoir quelqu'un qui
vient vous expliquer bah là voyez vous
avez une halogène quand vous l'allumez
ça fait grimper votre consommation votre
machine à laver elle est classe D si
vous en achetez une classe B ou a vous
allez baisser aussi votre consommation
tout ça ça nécessite des moyens
financiers pour avoir des moyens humains
à la hauteur et aussi des moyens
réglementaires de contrôle parce
qu'après la sensibilisation il faut
aussi parfois la coer oui vous dites
aussi il faut que l'État nous aide sur
le contrôle parce que il y a des
incivilités et puis il y a une une
réglementation à respecter et ça c'est
le rôle de de de l'État dans être le
gendarme voilà exactement quand des
personnes par exemple ne respectent pas
le le fait d'avoir 30 % d'espace qui
reste en pleine terre et bétonne parce
que ben voilà c'est plus pratique pour
remettre la voiture d'avoir du béton ou
du carrelage bah on n pas de moyens de
coerition suffisant ou pour toutes les
autres incivilités que que j'ai cité et
là on en aurait vraiment besoin voilà
voyez on est vraiment sur des des sujets
très concrets de votre liberté d'action
mais aussi d'un dialogue qui soit plus
cohérent et plus confluent avec les les
les services de l'État Michel P alors
autre réalité territoriale là vous êtes
dans une commune littorale de de l'ude
le C vous êtes aussi le vice-président
de la communauté d'agloot du Grand
Narbon et vous avez vous rencontré des
des problèmes très concrets
d'aménagement avec des des lois qui se
contredisent entre des objectifs de de
zan des objectif de loi littorale et de
pailu
oui
euh tout le monde ici partage je crois
le le désir la volonté en tout cas
d'avoir des des politiques adaptées au
plus près des du du
territoire au plus près des au plus près
des des communes la loi 3DS adopté voté
l'an dernier anné en est d'ailleurs en
est d'ailleurs l'expression euh mais il
faut que tout le monde effectivement
partage cette volonté d'un bout à
l'autre de de la chaîne du du
gouvernement si si j'ose dire jusque
effectivement à l'état local et euh et
et aux au préfets en particulier et puis
les administrations déconcentrées qui
dépendent de lui alors la le 3DS par
exemple pour l'exemple sur lequel vous
vous me sollicitez prévoit de manière
très explicite euh des possibilités
d'exemption de de production de de de
logements sociaux pour les communes qui
seraient frappé d'une forte
inconstructibilité en raison notamment
de la loi littorale ou ou des plans de
prévention des des risques donc une
mesure très très juste parce
qu'effectivement tout ne peut pas
s'appliquer de la même manière de
manière uniforme uniforme partout après
un calcul minutieux mené service de la
commune et et service de l'État local
préfet des
DTM pour ma commune pour le CAT donc ce
taux d'inconstructibilité des des
parties urbaines est effectivement
apparu calculé supérieur à 50 % ouvrant
ouvrant donc droit à cette à cette
exemption que la commune a naturellement
demandé et que le préfet tout aussi
naturellement lui a lui a accordé mais
donc vous aviez trouvé une solution nous
avions trouvé une solution ce qui ne
nous dispensait pas par ailleurs de
faire du logement social je je le
précise parce que même exempté sur
chaque opération on a quand même des
quotas
euh
mais l'état profond comme je le le
qualifierait craignant peut-être que
cette l'é profond ditil disposition
fasse euh face rapidement Tach d'huile
je ne sais pas euh
à suggérer au au préfet euh de rapporter
son son arrêté
euh en lui conseillant euh de revoir
effectivement ce calcul minutieux que
nous avions fait ensemble du taux
d'inconstructibilité ce que le préfet
évidemment a fait et il a donc rapporté
son son arrêté décision que la commune a
maintenant à maintenant attaquer cela
s'est passé je je le précise au même
moment quasiment quelques jours près où
la première ministre exhorait les
préfets justement à user davantage de
leur pouvoir de de
dérogation adaptation des politiques au
réalité locale et puis liberté d'action
de aussi des des préfets au côté des des
maires quand on on essaie de trouver des
des compromis acceptables et des
compromis possibles il existe de très
bons outils les nouvelles lois notamment
nous nous en donnent encore faut-il que
la la la volonté de les utiliser soit
partagé à à tous les étages de notre de
notre organisation alors on continue et
avant de vous donner la parole monsieur
le ministre vous écoutez tous ces
irritant toutes ces choses qui qui vont
à l'encontre des des politiques que que
vous portez et on termine ce premier
tour de table avant de de vous donner la
parole et l'occasion de de répondre avec
Patrick Jarry qui est le président de la
Fédération des entreprises publiques
locales qui était encore maire de
Nanterre il y a quelques quelques mois
et Patrick Jarry vous disiez bon ben nos
SEM nos entreprises publiques locales n
nos SPL d'aménagement sont aussi
entravés par des programmes nationaux
des des outils qui se chevauchent alors
qu'autrefois les les villes les interc
les aglos avaient la possibilité de
construire une stratégie d'aménagement
euh oui je évidemment les
les entreprises publiques locales sont
d'ailleurs peut-être un des éléments de
la
solution pour parvenir à mener toutes
ces politiques publiques j'y reviendrai
mais pour montrer la manière dont y
compris les choses peuvent se passer
très de décision pris par l'État et le
gouvernement automatisation du
remboursement du
FCTVA évidemment toutes les tout le
monde est tout le monde est content on
découvre que dans la mise en œuvre de ce
de ce de cette réforme euh d les les les
investissements des collectivités
territoriales des communes par exemple
pour acheter des terrains ne
bfinisseront plus de la du remboursement
de ce FCTVA au momentmême où comme cé
dit tout à l'heure évidemment la loisane
euh va compliquer les les pro jet
d'aménalement elle va aussi en renchirir
le coût hein puisque euh chacun comprend
bien que pour continuer de développer
des projets d'aménagement et notamment
des projets de logement qui sont
absolument euh nécessaires pour répondre
aux besoins on va construire euh sur des
endroit déjà construits où on va
reconstruire ces endroits déjà
construits et donc forcément ça coûte
plus cher alors petite euh le le montant
c'est 250 millions euh d'euros hein qui
euh qui passe à la trappe que que les
communes don les communes ou les
collectivités territoriales vénfici bon
on fait rétablir après donc 2 ans
d'effort c'est en 2021 loi de finance
2023 par l'intervention de la fédération
et puis des des
associations d'élus on arrive à faire
éétablir mais l'état le rétablit pas le
gouvernement ne donne pas l'accord pour
le rétablir sur les les équipements que
les collectivités territoriales font
construire dans le cadre des projets
d'aménagement chacun sait bien que
souvent v les collectivités
territoriales lorsqu'elles ont des
opérations d'aménagement et notamment
qui créent des logements elles font
financer les elle confie dans les
opérations d'aménagement les la
réalisation des équipements Bran voilà
donc un exemple dedans donc c'est encore
devant nous hein donc c'est évidemment
plusieurs dizaines de millions pour les
collectivités territoriales et je crois
que ça montre y compris parfois quand il
y a une réforme donc qui est positive
comment on on va instaurer un climat
méfiance entre les collectivités
territoriales et l'État alors que
l'intérêt serait faire autrement merci
Patrick Jarry alors ce climat de
méfiance monsieur le ministre on a cité
des des exemples très très concrets il
s'agit pas d'être ce matin dans le le
bureau des pleur mais d'être conscient
et bien de ces divergences de ces à peu
près qui qui coincent et puis qui
empêchent ce qui est le le thème de de
aussi de de l'AMF la liberté d'agir la
puissance
d'agir d'abord je suis ravi d'être là
ravi de de participer au
lancement de ce congrès et et ce moment
toujours un peu particulier j'en parle
pour les 10 ans où je suis venu ici en
tant que maire pour les 10 années
précédentes où j'étais eu municipale
sans être maire et même si l'accueil du
coup qui m'est réservé en tant que
ministre y compris en étant le plat
principal de la table sur où le punching
ball qui qui qui permet de de commencer
en se réveillant
collectivement je suis ravi d'être là
parce que je pense que rien n'est pire
que d'avoir des choses qui m'asserent et
de pas se les dire et en vrai l'État et
les collectivités sont soumises à des
défis qui sont assez
comparables et il m'arrive de retrouver
dans les expressions des mares par
rapport au gouvernement ce que
j'entendais de la part des expressions
de mes habitants par rapport au maire
que
j'étais donc je vais pas minimiser ça je
vais juste dire que quelle que soit
l'échelle à laquelle vous trouvez quand
vous êtes responsable de quelque chose
vous êtes y compris parfois responsable
de choses où vous vous dites que c'est
un tout petit peu plus complexe que la
manière dont on vous le décrit
un je me réjouis que ce congrès il
commence sur comment collectivement on
réussit le défi de la transition
écologique parce qu'il y a quelques
années si on se dit les choses sur un
débat comme celui-là on aurait peut-être
pu àoir est-ce que oui ou non il faut
accélérer sur la transition écologique
là il y a pas de sujet Quel que soit la
tendance deséc obctivité le sujet c'est
comment on y va et il y a une hauteur de
marche objective les chiffres ils font
froid dans le dos quel que soit la
manière dont on les prend le témoignage
de la m de la possession sur la richesse
incroyable en terme de biodive qui
existe à la Réunion c'est vrai à la
minute où on se passe on se parle on a
une espèce sur H sur cette planète qui
est menacée
d'extinction donc la réalité derrière
est une explosion des espèces
endémiques le climat les chiffres d'hier
et d'avan-hier au rythme o on va c'est
pas l'accord de Paris 1 et demi qu'on
tiendra on sera plutôt entre 25 et 28 ce
qui veut dire adapter notre pays à une
température qui sera de l'ordre de
4°grés à la fin du
siècle et en face de ça ce qui emmerde
le plus nos concitoyens pour utiliser un
mot un peu pidolen un peu
vulgaire avant que ce
soit les éoliennes le zan les ZFE et les
ABF
ce sont les conséquences extrêmement
concrètes de ce dérèglement
climatique c'est la sécheresse quand
vous avez plus d'eau c'est le fait de
vous retrouver avec des éboulements
comme dans la vzubi c'est le fait de
vous retrouver avec des épisodes de
catastrophes naturelles qui vont se
succéder et notre ennemi ce sont pas les
façons dont on lutte c'est ce
dérèglement et le fait qu'on ne souhaite
pas que ça s'amplifie que ça s'accentue
avec un inconnu dans la pièce qui qui
est le coût de l'inaction et on pense
bien sûr ce matin au au maire du pas
decalé en particulier tous ceux qui
doivent faire face à ces inondations et
ces épisodes climatiques de plus en plus
violents et fréquents bien entendu qu'on
pense à eux et je peux vous dire que
là-bas de façon très concrète autant
quand je me déplace il m'arrive qu'on
m'explique que quand même les pprrii
c'est sacrément compliqué parce que ça
prive des territoires dans lequel on
peut pas construire et c'est trop rigide
quand vous êtes là-bas vous comprenez à
quoi sert un pper quand vous avez une
usine qui récente qui n'est pas touchée
par l'eau et que de l'autre côté vous
avez un site qui est sous l'eau et qui
correspond à la zone inondable du pépéri
je je vais pas avancer là-dessus mais
indirectement la bataille du zan c'est
quand même pour éviter qu'on se retrouve
en bouchon non naable fréatique à
multiplier les endroits dans lequels on
a de l'eau qui au lieu de s'infiltrer
ruisselle et accentue une partie des
difficultés que nous connaissons
maintenant les amis on va pas se mentir
un tout ça là tout ce dont on est en
train de parler il y a pas un pays au
monde qui a trouvé le bon rythme et la
bonne formule pour aller faire la
transition écologique il y en a pas un
donc nous cherchons on essaie de trouver
la bonne formule et la bonne formule
elle est quelque part dans un triangle
où il faut que l'État assume et prenne
des responsabilités tit de la sphère
publique que les citoyens s'y mettent
parce que le petit discours qui consiste
à penser qu'il suffirait d'interdire les
jets
pour aller régler le problème de la
transition écologique sans demander aux
gens d'aller faire des efforts ça marche
pas et que le point de jonction entre
les deux c'est les collectivités
territoriales parce que c'est
l'endroit dans lequel les politiques
nationales se déclinent quand je dis
qu'il faut faire en sorte de bouger sur
les transports super mais c'est pas
parce que vous faites voter un plan vélo
qui a plus de gens qui prennent le vélo
c'est pas parce que vous augmentez un
niveau d'aide au niveau du Parlement sur
l'aide à l'achat des VAE que ça
fonctionne c'est parce qu'il y a un
maire qui dessine une piste cyclable
sécurisée dans sa commune et qu'à ce
moment-là ça déclenche le fait d'y aller
c'est vrai sur les transports en commun
c'est la question de l'offre ça l'est
sur la Politique des déchets dont on a
parlé il y a quelques minutes avec des
réalités territoriales les amis qui sont
diverses oui je je je me suis opposé à
la généralisation d'une consigne qui
aurait été un objet techno sur toute la
France mais la m'oblige à dire
qu'aujourd'hui dans ce pays où la
liberté est laissée aux élus locaux on a
des taux de collecte et de recyclage des
bouteilles plastiques qui varient de 40
à 90 % en fonction des endroits du
territoire c'est moins simple de
défendre par rapport à une partie de
l'administration centrale le fait qu'il
faut pas mettre la collecte quand vous
avez des villes à 40 que quand vous avez
des villes à 90 et quand on utilise
celle là pour vous dire qu'on est très
en retard et qu'on sera jamais au 90 % à
la fin de la décennie ça suppose
effectivement d'être dans un dispositif
on pourra en reparler dans le cadre de
la r emballage où on est capable de
d'avancer mais là il fa
pasueux avant de répondre au au aux
questions parce que je je pourrais
multiplier les réponses je vous donne
peut-être deux ou trois éclairage en
tout cas sur la manière dont on
s'efforce d'avancer et puis après on
donnera la parole au congressist de la
salle qui pourront témoigner et aussi
peut-être faire des des propositions
allez-y monsieur alors d'abord pour
commencer ma philosophie mais sans doute
parce que je viens de ce monde des élus
locaux ça a été de mettre en place un
fond vert qui ne repose ni sur un appel
à projet ni sur un appel à manifestation
d'intérêt et qui a été victime de ce
succès puisqueà la minute où nous
parlons ce sont 8000 collectivités de ce
pays qui se partage les 2 milliards
d'euros de la première édition et ce
fond nous passons le montant à 2
milliards et demi ces 2 milliards
d'euros ils ont entraîné 10 milliards
d'euros d'investissement des
collectivités territoriales quand quand
on résume les projets ce qui quand on se
rapproche du mur d'investissement ou de
la finance climat permet de mesurer
l'importance de cette effet de levier et
en disant c'est vous qui savez le mieux
ce qui est bon chez vous le problème
c'est qu'il y a tellement de besoin que
2 milliards ne suffisait pas 2 milliards
et demi par an jusqu'à la fin du
quinquena c'est juste plus que le
doublement des enveloppes
d'investissement qui existent par le
passé puisque d plus descil ensemble
c'est 2
milliards
de la nouvelle étape qui commence c'est
celle de la territorialisation de la
planification alors deux mots de quatre
syllabes dans la même phrase ça en fait
au moins trop mais en essayant de de
résumer les choses de façon très ultra
rapide c'est exactement l'objet de cette
table ronde j'étais dans le Grand T la
semaine dernière je vais la semaine
prochaine j'installe sud ocitanie et
aquit on dit au régions voilà quel est
le diagnostic voilà quelles sont les
émissions à vous de nous dire les
secteurs et les domaines par lesquels
vous souhaitez commencer et on vous
demande pas de le faire à l'échelle
régionale on vous demande d'animer à
l'échelle des départements et des
communes la remontée de ce qui a déjà
été décidé de manière à ce que la
consolidation de ces initiatives locales
nous permettent d'atteindre l'ambition
qu'on s'est fixé alors vous parlez de
cette concertation régionale il y a la
question justement jusqu'où doivent
aller les les cops régional leur aspect
normatif concertation planification
apparemment c'est pas complètement clair
he Monsieur P monsieur le ministre a
déjà largement commencé à répondre
effectivement la la la transition
écologique nécessite la définition d'une
trajectoire précise pour atteindre les
objectifs de de réduction d'emprunte
carbone par par secteur et donc on a
besoin pour cela d'un cadre global la
territoralisation elle est tout aussi
indispensable car les collectivités
locales euh disposent de par le
compétence d'un certain nombre de
leviers et sont aussi parfois également
à l'origine d'initiatives qui peuvent
qui peuvent faire école toute la
question maintenant que l'on se pose
c'est de savoir comment cette
territorialisation va va s'opérer à
travers ces ces conférence de de partis
à travers ces copes elles ne peuvent pas
être mais je je ne pense pas que ça soit
le cas uniquement l'œuvre de de de
l'État local et et des régions et ell ne
peut pas consister à donner juste des
des objectif à atteindre aux
collectivités il faut bien qu' soit des
instances de de dialogue au sein
desquelles les collectivités pourront
faire valoir et à la fois ce qu'elles
ont déjà fait ce qu'elles sont prêtes à
faire en un mot leur
trajectoire éventuellement discutter
éventuellement corrigé pour qu'elle
permetteent d'atteindre effectivement
les objectifs globaux que nous avons
collectivement à à poursuiv à atteindre
c'est exactement l'objectif on a une
ambition qui ne se dis discute pas parce
que l'ambition c'est tenir nos
engagements climatiques et on donc on
sait le point des mission auquel on doit
aller en
revanche l'idée c'est d'additionner la
souplesse du terrain vous êtes dans un
endroit où vous décidez de mettre le
paquet sur la géothermie parce que vous
avez une opportunité dans un autre
endroit sur le biométhane dans un 3è sur
la biodiversité parce que c'est votre
premier combat dans un 4e sur de la
déminéralisation ou sur de la
dépollution de friche dans un 5e sur du
remplacement de candélab pour enlever
une partie de vos ampoules thermiques
peu importe l'important c'est que la
c'est que tout le monde se mette en
mouvement et fasse en sorte sur ces
leviers de biodiversité d'atténuation ou
d'adaptation qu'on soit en capacité
d'avancer et nous faisons confiance au
terrain avec une attente c'est que la
somme de ça ça boucle si ça boucle pas
ça veut dire qu'à ce moment-là il faut
qu'on mesure ce que sont les écarts et
comment on doit avancer avec à la fin un
sujet c'est que le
crte soit financièrement doté et que ce
contrat qui aujourd'hui a un mérite
c'est de recenser ce qui existe ce soit
l'objet qui permet dans la planification
on va pas réinventer des dispositifs on
va pas réinventer un nouveau contrat
alors que déjà il a fallu du temps pour
être capable de le remplir de les
renseigner en revanche il faut que les
outils qui existent on soit plus
pragmatique dans la manière dont on les
utilise et qu'en clair les tuyaux des
projets arrivent en face des tuyaux des
financements et qu'on est pas
aujourd'hui de circuits par qui ne se
croise pas c'est l'objectif et
l'ambitionors plusieurs demandes de de
prise de de parole madame allez-y vous
présentez s'il vous plaît oui
bonjour bonjour Florence Presson adjoint
au maire parlez bien près du micro pour
qu'on vous bonjour Florence Presson
adjoint au mer sur la ville de sa je
voudrais vous parler de la rénovation
énergétique et particulièrement des
logements aujourd'hui quasiment tous les
élus qui sont là sont mobilisés
accompagnent les ménages par ailleurs
vous avez de ministres
de femmes madame vargon AG P runach qui
font un travail extraordinaire des
équipes l'équipe de Simon hufto l'équipe
à les sal aussi vous mettez des moyens
cependant je pense qu'on ntiendra pas
les objectifs de rénovation pourquoi je
prends un exemple rénovation énergétique
performante c'est de l'investissement ça
nécessite des
prêts moins de 15 % des ménages
obtiennent des prêts bancaires
la banque ne joue pas le jeu alors une
mesure qui vous coûterait rien mais qui
pourrait être par exemple de mettre des
étoiles sur les banques une banque qui
fait moins de 3 % de prêt en nombre de
prêt pour la rénovation énergétique par
rapport au nombre total de prêt et bien
pas d'étoile un une étoile s' fond de 3
à 5 est-ce que nous allons tous
continuer est-ce que les habitants vont
continuer à aller dans les banques qui
sont à zéro étoile ou à une étoile donc
là ça nécessite pas d'argent c'est une
volonté politique voilà merci passez le
micro à votre collègue derrière vous on
va prendre plusieurs prises de
parole oui Paul Savatier maire de
Saint-Vincent de Barès en Ardèche une
commune de 856
habitants il est beaucoup question
depuis le début hein de de ce congrès
c'est très bien de la confiance dans le
micro qu'on vous entend de la confiance
des citoyens dans leurs élus et dans la
République et je pense qu'effectivement
cette confiance passe d' voilà pour les
premiers échanges de ce 105e congrès des
maires de France cette table ronde qui
se tient ce matin dans le Grand
Auditorium sur le thème de la réussite
de la transition écologique dans le
respect des libertés locales et vous
venez de le voir Christophe Béchu le
ministre de la transition écologique qui
fait partie de la quinzaine de ministres
à être venu ici et bien lors de ce
congrès échanger avec des maires et cela
lance et bien les débats de ce congrès
qui se tient jusqu'à jeudi avec de
grandes émissions autour de ce grand
direct sur Public Sénat depuis le parc
des expositions de la Porte de
Versailles prochain rendez-vous c'est à
18h avec Thomas HUG dans sens public qui
sera sur ce plateau également à 11h
demain vous retrouverez Alexandre
Poussard n'hésitez pas enfin à lire les
décryptages sur publsena.fr merci à
toutes les équipes techniques et
éditoriales qui ont réalisé ce grand
direct à très vite sur public
[Musique]
scena voir ou revoir votre
programme sur
publicsenat.fr tout de suite sur public
[Musique]
sa la peur du taliban coule dans notre
sang du coup ma mère ne pense qu'à nous
enfermer je suis sur le balcon elle me
ramène à l'intérieur de la maison et
quand elle entend des bruits trop forts
elle a si peur qu'elle cour se caché
dans le placard depuis le 15 août 2021
les femmes afghanes vivent un calvaire
un cauchemar les talibans tentent de les
effacer du paysage de les gommé de
l'espace public ils les rendent
invisibles Solen chalvon fiorityti leur
redonne leur voix et leur visage dans un
documentaire choc afghan comment après
20 ans d'intervention internationale
l'Afghanistan a-t-il pu en arriver là
avons-nous abandonné les femmes afghan
je vous retrouve juste après le film
pour en débattre avec nos invités